[Music]
no no this is not happening
Oh God Lily
Garret
willing I'm here where are you oh gosh
upstairs
how did this happen
I'm coming Lily just hold on
dear Lily I'm here
Lily come on out
Lily where are you I'm here dad's here
you weren't here for me dad
kidman hello Sebastian it's been a long
time three years I've been trying to
track you down for three years and you
thought you'd find me at the bottom of
an empty bottle is that it and why are
you here now dammit you didn't find me
because they didn't want you to calm
down Sebastian
you knew what was gonna happen in that
hospital didn't you what happened at
vegan is in the past you need to forget
it you sound just like that psychologist
that force shoved down my throat but he
didn't have answers you do you're gonna
tell me about Mobius
I'm here because of this where did you
get this Lily's still alive Lily is dead
I read the police report I was at her
funeral we can rewrite history if we
want to staging a death is child's play
why would I come out of the shadows just
to lie to you Lily is alive and she's
with us but she's in danger we need you
to help save her
safer what have you done to her get your
hands off me
I was hoping you'd come willingly
Sebastian oh we don't have time for this
[ __ ] Lily needs you Sebastian
you're awake good yeah great where are
we you're in one of our facilities so
this is the Almighty Mobius huh be
careful about what you say you don't
know how powerful they are right so
powerful they have to kidnap a washed-up
ex-cop to help them at least your
terrible sense of humor is still intact
enough of this [ __ ] where's Lily
patience all your answers are right here
The Beacon mental hospital incident was
an unfortunate setback but we used a
knowledge gained to build a new and
vastly improved stem system what does
this have to do with my daughter imagine
it millions of minds connected together
happiness for one is happiness for all
this machine this miracle will allow our
species to achieve greatness we needed
to start with a mind that was pure and
clean enough to support thousands of
personalities the mind of an innocent
child
you connected lily to that machine your
daughter is quite special the most
stable core candidate we've ever tested
thanks to her the new stem has been a
smashing success until recently a little
over a week ago
Lily vanished just stop sending signals
then the stem environment began to
collapse we thought it was just a
technical glitch an easy fix so we sent
a team of Mobius agents inside but then
we lost contact with them and stem went
dark think about this mr. Castellanos I
am providing you an opportunity not only
to see your daughter again but to save
her life something you thought you
failed to do before
you can save her or let her die
it's your choice good luck Sebastian and
please try to cooperate with any team
members you might find in there I know
you don't trust us but they have the
same goals as you do that's alright I'm
fine by myself just remember to call me
the moment you find Lilly so that we can
begin the extraction process I'll be out
here for you
and someone else will be in there for
you
are you ready
[Music]
be careful in there Sebastian we're
counting on you
[Music]
stem entry in three two one
[Music]
[Music]
brought to you by the evil within to the
evil within - available October 13th